tu te souviens comment tu te souviens comment
Alice n'était pas toujours au pays des merveilles elle
est tombée au fond d'un trou ouais
eh bien je n'étais pas toujours dans la chambre je suis comme
Alice j'étais une petite fille nommée joie ouais
et j'ai vécu dans  une maison avec ma mère et
mon père tu les appellerais grand-mère et grand-
père comment c'était une maison dans le monde
il y avait un jardin nous avions un hamac nous
nous balancions dans le hamac nous mangeons de la
glace keely house no jack une vraie maison
pas la télé es-tu  même en m'écoutant quand
j'étais un peu plus âgé quand j'avais 17 ans je
rentrais chez moi tu étais toujours au
paradis mais il y avait un gars il prétendait
que son chien était un gars vieux Nick nous l'
appelons vieux Nick je ne sais pas  sais quel est son vrai
nom mais il a prétendu que son chien était des
chiens rouges à lèvres aujourd'hui
Hector n'était pas un chien, il essayait de
me tromper d'accord il n'y avait pas un vieux chien
après m'a dit que je voulais devenir riche histoire
non c'est l'histoire que vous  il m'a mis
dans son abri de jardin ici la chambre est l'abri